اناكون انتقل انا الى قصه حسين وحسن هما
توام يحترف الرسم ويؤسسان الميلاد في
موريتانيا من خلال الرسم على الجدران
الهيئات الثقافيه والشوارع قلب مدينه
نواخشوط تركز على التوام في رسوماتما على
القضايا المسؤول عنها اجتماعيا كما يسعيان
الى الاقتباس من التراث المحلي في لوحاته
في بيت العائله
حتى اصبحا محترفين
اهتم التوام بمدارس وانماط مختلفه من
الرسم منذ سنوات ثم ركز مؤخرا على فني
ديغرافيتي
لا بدنا نعد هدول هو
زينه المنازل والشوارع طبعا هو عايز
القضايا الاجتماعيه
[موسيقى]
عامل الفنان الشابه هند ضمن مشروع تطوعي
بمعيه عدد من الفنانين لتزيين بعض الشوارع
والمباني
لوحات مثلا نتكلم عن ثقافه الاسلاميه
يعد لك رافتين من فنون الرسم قليله
الانتشار في موريتانيا ما يدفع حسن وحسين
ورفاقهما الى توطين هذا النمط الفني من
خلال اقناع الفنانين الشباب
بالانخراط في ودفع الجهات الثقافيه
الرسميه والاهليه الى تشجيعه ابراهيم
مصطفى العربيه